so let's start with the first concrete
example so we'll start with the first uh
kind of successful blockchain called the
bitcoin blockchain and we'll see let's
see how that works so in bitcoin
basically um again we have a blockchain
which is essentially a sequence of
blocks so here you see
block number you know n minus 1 is
represented here block number n is
represented here
and so on and so forth you see that
every block has a certain set of
transactions inside of it so block n
minus 1 has four transactions in it
uh block number n has also four
transactions in it so really basically
you can see that the blockchain is
basically maintaining a sequence of of
these blocks um and there's a strong
ordering and the blocks themselves are
sorry the transactions themselves are
grouped into blocks
so that every block contributes a new
set of transactions into the blockchain
now these things up here that
i refer to as the blocks well those are
actually called the block headers
and in fact they're quite short a block
header literally contains these four
fields here one field called a hash
another field called the timestamp the
transactions and announce
i'm not going to go into the details of
what these things are i'll just tell you
that sort of the transaction hash hash
is a very small value essentially 32
bytes of data
this transaction hash basically
represents all the transactions that
were added within a particular block
we'll see how that's done again in just
a minute
and the reason we call it a chain is
because all these block headers are
chained together so what do we mean by
that what we mean is essentially you
take
all the data in block number n minus one
and again you hash it into a short
string a 32 byte string and that hash is
written into the next block okay so
essentially we take block number n minus
one compress it using a hash function
and we write that into block number n we
write the resulting hash into block
number n so in some sense block number n
contains inside of it a representation
of everything a block number minus 1 and
because block number n minus one can say
it contains inside of it a
representation of block n minus two sort
of recursively um every block contains
some sort of uh uh dependency on
everything that came before it in the
blockchain okay so this is why um
there's a serial c uh
progression of blocks where essentially
every block kind of depends on all
previous blocks that came before it so
this is again specific to the
blockchains there are more recent
designs of blockchains that in fact are
not necessarily there's not necessarily
a strict ordering of blocks but in the
bitcoin blockchain in fact there is such
a strict ordering and that actually
defines a strict ordering of
transactions that were added to the
blockchain so i promised you to explain
what a hash function is and what a hash
is so let's do that quickly because this
is going to be used a lot throughout
the lectures
so what is a hash function basically a
hash function is basically i'll denote
it by h and essentially it's just a
computable efficiently computable
function that takes arbitrary data as
inputs and produces a 32 byte output so
you can imagine like gigabytes of data
going in yeah this could be literally
gigabytes of data and the hash function
just produces 32 bytes as a result okay
so every time i refer to a hash value
what i mean is just 32 bytes of data
that gets written into a particular
field all right so that's what a hash
function is and hash functions can have
a variety of properties the property
that's most common is what's called
collision resistance which means that
it's difficult to find two distinct
inputs that happen to map to the same
output in other words it's kind of hard
to find you know data number one in data
number two let's call it d1 and d2 so
that if i hash this data and i hash data
number two i end up with the same two
the same 32 bytes
hash value as a result yeah this would
be a collision because uh d1 and d2
happen to map to the same output so if
it's hard to find collisions we say the
hash function is collision resistant and
this is actually necessary for many of
the things that we're going to be using
hash functions for
okay good
um so in the bitcoin blockchain just to
kind of be concrete you can see that
there are lots of blocks that have
already been assembled so in this slide
you see that blocks sort of progress in
time from the bottom to the top so
here's block number five hundred forty
thousand eight fifty five five hundred
forty thousand eight fifty six um and so
on and so forth you can see that every
block is added roughly roughly every ten
minutes this is the design of the
bitcoin network in this case there were
actually two blocks added at the same
time but generally there's uh there uh
there's a new block that's added every
10 minutes
since the beginning of time so since
2009 there's been a new block
added roughly every 10 minutes you can
see that every block contains about a
thousand transactions uh yeah so new a
thousand new transactions are added uh
in every block and these transactions
basically transfer bitcoin from one
address from one bitcoin address to
another you can see that if you sum up
all the transfers um in this in this
block over here there were 3 000
bitcoins transferred in that one
particular block 3 000 bitcoins with
today's value translates to about what
is it about
seven million dollars so you can see
just in those uh in that one particular
block that was added in a 10-minute
window there were seven million dollars
worth of transfers uh in bitcoins okay
and in fact uh there's a really
beautiful website called blockchain.com
that gives you a lot of information
about the bitcoin uh blockchain i
actually encourage you to kind of go
play with this website and you can kind
of see all sorts of statistics about
what's happening with the bitcoin
network the bitcoin blockchain and you
can see how much money is being
transferred uh how many blocks are
created and so on so let's look at one
particular transaction i keep using the
word transaction but i didn't really
explain what a transaction is so let's
look at one particular transaction in
one of the blocks that we just saw yeah
so i picked on block number
540856 that's one of the blocks we saw
before
what we see here basically in this block
is one particular transaction so let me
explain what this transaction is so here
we see two different uh bitcoin accounts
if you like or what are called bitcoin
addresses again we'll see what addresses
are in just a minute but essentially two
bitcoin accounts are contributing funds
to this transaction
and those funds are going to two other
accounts which are specified here yeah
so these are called the two input
addresses these are called the two
output addresses
and what we're seeing basically is that
one address received you know this
amount of bitcoin
0.006 and so on and the other address
received this amount of bitcoin 0.017
and so on yeah so the total input is you
know this amount the total output is
this amount and the difference between
the input and the outputs is what's
called the transaction fee okay so
somebody gets to keep this fee
and the person that gets to keep this
fee is what we call the miner that
actually added this transaction into a
block which was then added to the
blockchain okay so we'll talk about how
miners operate later on in the lecture
okay so one miner basically took this
transaction from the user
embedded it in a block and then
published the block to the blockchain
and that miner was compensated uh for
that effort by these particular
transaction fees as well as some other
fees that again we'll see in in just a
little bit okay so from every
transaction that was embedded in the
block the miner got to collect some fees
so if there are a thousand transactions
embedded in a block the miner gets to
collect you know a thousand fees one
from each of these transactions
um and i want to kind of emphasize again
this is a i'll repeat the slide i want
to emphasize again that the blockchain
itself is replicated across lots and
lots of parties i want you to remember
this terminology that the miners are the
one who writes to the blockchain the end
users kind of monitor their own state in
the blockchain and the service providers
basically process data on the blockchain
to kind of understand uh what's going on
in the system
everyone could validate transactions in
the blockchain and invalid blocks are
immediately blocked immediately dropped
and
everyone basically agrees on the same
data that's that's actually placed on
the blockchain okay now some of these
things may be a little opaque at this
point but i promise by the end of the
lecture everything will be completely
clear